thank you
before Rome
before Babylon
before the pyramids
there was conduct
the first self-governing people on Earth
conduct was the center of power and
enlightenment
for centuries they thrived
but then
King King Acton
using the Army disease power Acton
became a tyrant but he had even darker
ambitions
obsessed with dark magic octon's real
goal
was to forge the crown of sabach
if infused with the powers of the six
Demons of the ancient world
it would make octone invincible
to make the crown he needed
a rare mineral of Magic Properties found
only in conduct
so he enslaved his own people
who forced them to dig
[Music]
[Music]
kanak was teetering on the brink
what they needed
was a hero
foreign
[Music]
done a date on me as a cultivated
someone to hold the hopes of the people
[Music]
even when all hope seems lost
[Music]
King Arthur knew that this spark could
quickly not a fire
and so he ordered that he'd be snuffed
out
the Council of wizards the magical
Guardians of the Earth
sought to restore the balance
they empowered him with the gift of the
ancient gods entered a boy
into a champion
it means join battle
the palace was destroyed but the
champion was Victorious
the Wizards hid the crown of sabak so
that it would never again fall into the
hands of men
and the champion was never heard from
again the world is
today conduct is occupied by
International mercenaries that enter
game the latest in a series of foreign
Invaders
but Legend says whenever conduct needs
him most the champion will return to
restore freedom to the people
it has been a long long wait
[Music]
your documentation ready
it's only three documents yeah don't
judge the pictures after my girlfriend
broke up with me
open it back need to look inside
yes unlocked man
it's just a bunch of old TVs I'm an
electrician
foreign
I'm heartbroken
now go on no you are is a new
imperialist enforcer from Halfway Around
the World Center to steal my country's
natural resources strip mine our sacred
lens pollute our Waters oppress Our
Heritage and make us wait in lines all
day
hey boss man
can I go
on get out of here
[Music]
conduct isn't safe for us anymore
first thing
and then we could save I got into game
watching my house I gave up my job at
the University and
it doesn't mean I'm gonna
I'm just saying no one stays
I can't wait for things to cool down
this time if I'm right they're days away
from finding it
no it's too dangerous you shouldn't have
gotten involved come on I would help you
beat those
Brianna keep your head down please you
want to be a hero huh I do yeah go home
do your homework your time will come one
day
is it good
that would get you a fortune on the
black market
is that really
show us a little magic
doesn't work like that it's unrefined
you guys should get some rest I thought
into Gang season on the old relics come
on stop it I'm just curious how she got
it my grandmother gave it to me how did
she get it's not a museum piece
it's a family heirloom going all the way
back to the days
you happy now
full story
no I inherited with a sweater that's not
true Bobby Lefty was van in his bald
spot you know some women like a bald
spot apparently on the outside smooth on
the inside
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
are you sure about this the inscriptions
we found are clear
and I'm positive about that translation
there is something inside